he said his grandmother died and he
could not accept the fact that his
grandmother was going to the Hellfire so
he left
Islam that's
it his grandmother died he couldn't
accept the fact that she was going to
Hellfire and therefore he decided to
join her he left
Islam right now now let's look at the S
there's a woman named durra and I want
you guys to tell me who her family is
this woman named durra she was from the
companions may be pleased to her this
woman was informed that her mother and
father were going to the Hellfire but
they were both
alive and she was informed by a very
reliable source the most reliable source
in the
universe right
her father was ABAB her mother
was J right when the daughter of Abu
lahab migrated to al- Medina some people
said to her you are the daughter of the
fire or the firewood of hell they said
to her you are the daughter of the
firewood of hell you imagine that now
when the prophet Alam heard this and
what relation was she to him she was his
cousin he said what's the matter with
some people that they they offend my
lineage and my kin folk surely whoever
offends my lineage and my kin folk has
offended me and whoever offends me has
offended
Allah but that woman that great Noble
woman May pleases her she was firm she
didn't let that what the people said
make her leave Islam or or make her
upset she was firm she was patient with
that right another example and this will
be the last example and we'll end with
this there's a man another man that I
know personally
and he was living in a Muslim country
and some difficulty befel him and the
Muslims didn't help him this man had
been s his whole life he left his L
because of
this because a Muslim didn't help him
don't you understand that if you travel
to a Muslim country you're going to find
some racism
there you going to find people that are
racist you're going to find people that
are mean you're going to find people
that are going to steal from you what
does it have to do with your lord
nothing what does have to do with your
religion nothing that's that person
right
now Malik man pleasing him he stayed
back from the Battle
of tabuk and thus by the command of
Allah T the Muslims boycotted him and
the Christians tried to persuade him to
leave Islam he said while I was walking
in the market of Medina I saw a
Christian farmer from Shem who came to
sell his grains in Medina he was saying
who will lead me to Malik and the people
begin to point me out and he came to me
and handed me a letter from the king of
gasan and the letter read to proceed I
have been informed that your friend
meaning who the prophet Alam has treated
you harshly Allah does not allow you to
live in a place where you feel inferior
and your right is lost so join us and we
will console you see how I try to use
Islam Allah don't allow that to happen
to
you Cam he said when I read the letter I
said to myself this is also a test so I
took the letter to the oven and made
fire with
it now I'm going tell you something that
happened to
me when I was in Yemen and this is how
these stories can become practical when
something happens to you you think back
okay this is how K responded so let me
try to respond similar he's much greater
than me but I'm trying to emulate
him when I was in Yemen there was a
friend of
mine Abdullah Allah preserve him he's a
brother of my close friend Abu Allah
preserve him also he was studying with
us the brother Idris in D so it was HJ
season so he wanted to make Hajj his
mother was going to meet him on Hajj so
he went um to get his Hajj paperwork and
they locked him him up and he had a Visa
so I'm trying to be the good friend said
okay well I'm sure his mother's worried
I'm going to go get his mother's phone
number from him so I can call his mother
this this was before we had cell phon y
I said I'm going to get his mother's
phone number I'm going to visit him
where inside the jail get his mother's
phone number call his mother and let her
know he he's not coming so I went to the
jail and I said look I want to visit the
brother ad so I get his mother they said
okay oh you you like to see him okay
he's right there in that jail so they
showed me he was at they locked me
up they locked me up and it was the the
the H season so you know okay you'll get
out
b
b chabana means
what it means Allah knows best right
so I was inside of the jail just waiting
and I had a Visa too and after the Hajj
you know we spent the Eid and of course
when you in in prison or jail there in
the Muslim country you're not doing the
Eid prayer there right so we spent the
Eid there and you know there's no one
phone call we just there we just there
and after the Eid the warden came back
in town and and so they said okay the
warden wants to see you and and of
course the jail is you know a little bit
you know it's kind of raggedy you know
so they blindfold
me they walk me up the stairs and they
sit me in front of the warden and
he's yelling at me in Arabic he's you
know really badgering me and everything
and and then all a sudden he gets real
calm and he says okay take out the
blindfold and I take it off and he said
do you know why you are being deported I
said no and I was real respectful he's
my ELD no I'm he said because the
American government says if we catch any
student from sh Muk Bill send them home
told me that said the American
government said we catch any student sh
M send them home and so they sent us
home and I had that one th on and I was
wearing a house stove and this is no
offense I'm sorry somebody got a house
stove on here but you know the house
stove that's just the stove that you
wear you know the sleevess stove house
sto and I had that one th for the whole
time I was in the jail you know and so
they they sent us back and
so I'm from North Carolina adri is from
Jersey
and they gave us a ticket to JFK and so
I'm talking to the counselor from
America I said okay I'm from North
Carolina the ticket says JFK they said I
know where it
say get North Carolina the best way you
can but Allah T brought out some good
from that but there's a Shah to this all
right so when the preacher that from the
church that I knew my whole life when he
heard about what happened he said to my
mother he said don't worry about that he
said when he sees how the Muslims
treated him he'll be back in church on
Sunday so they're always waiting always
waiting by Allah's Mercy I wasn't in
church on
Sunday alhamdulillah I was patient with
it you know but sh is that they're
they're always waiting but just thinking
about what happened to people better
than me whenever something happens to me
I remind myself something better
happened to somebody better than me
whenever somebody says something
negative about me I said somebody says
something worse about somebody better
than me I don't say why not me I say I
don't say why me I say why not me who am
I not to be tried if if people better
than me have been tried with worse than
what I'm tried with so that's just my
story Yan personal story andah I'll
mention more benefits about my prison
time and actually I went back to Yen
after that and they kicked me out
again so but I'll tell that story later
on I'm not going to bore youall with
that story